niederlage für novak djokovic
der serbische tennis da hat den kampf
gegen seine abschiebung aus australien
verloren einen tag vor dem start der
australian open wie es ein bundesgericht
in melbourne djokovic einspruch gegen
den entzug seines visums zurück das
gericht hat beschlossen dass der
abgeänderte antrag kostenpflichtig
abzuweisen ist erklärte der vorsitzende
richter james hook nach der entscheidung
djokovic muss also nicht nur das land
verlassen sondern auch die
gerichtskosten tragen djokovic hatte bei
seiner einreise statt eines corona
impfnachweis eine medizinische
ausnahmegenehmigung
vorgelegt bis zu seiner ausreise muss er
nun in gewahrsam bleiben die teilnahme
an den australian open in melbourne die
er bereits neun mal gewonnen hat bleibt
ihm verwehrt